the biomass satellite is finally taking
shape
this is our last chance to visit it in
its dust-free clean room before it
leaves the uk for pre-launch tests
as science missions go it's a big one
and it has to be it's folded up like an
umbrella along its side is a 12 meter
radar antenna it really will be quite um
quite a sight i think to the whole you
can't really simulate what it's going to
be like in space fully on the ground so
it's all essentially modelling at this
stage so it'll be quite exciting to see
that happen
the collapsible antenna is crucial to
its mission to see from the cold
emptiness of space the humid woody
depths of earth's forests in a
completely new way at the heart of the
biomass satellite is something called a
p-band radar and it's the first time
that technology has flown into space and
it gives scientists the power to look
through the forest canopy at what's
below essentially allowing them for the
first time to see the wood for the trees
if you look to the other forest with
this wavelength the
leaves and little branches will be
totally invisible the tree would look
like a tree that's just all the leaves
stripped off and most small tricks left
off and it would just look like a the
framework of a tree and that's where the
biomass is
forests are fundamental to global
warming because through photosynthesis
they turn about a third of the carbon we
pump into the atmosphere into biomass
yet how much carbon they actually
contain is largely guesswork
particularly in dense tropical forests
i've measured tens of thousands of trees
across the tropics in the amazon in the
congo basin but there's only so many
trees you can measure by hand right but
what this satellite can do is tell us
what's happening over enormous areas if
you look at a tree trunk like about 50
percent of the dry weight will be carbon
and knowing how much carbon there is in
forests is crucial as we continue to cut
or burn them down
we know that we're in this climate
emergency and we've got to get emissions
right down really rapidly and one of the
key uncertainties
is how much carbon is going into the
atmosphere from deforestation and from
exactly where as well as measuring the
stores of carbon we're losing the
biomass satellite can also reveal the
most carbon-rich forests we have to
protect and help hold to account those
who've promised to protect them
tom clark sky news